well thank you for that that
production I reminded of a New Yorker
cartoon where somebody after the
introduction somebody in the audience
looks to their partner and says he can't
hold down a job Kenny in fact if you
were to plot it it seems like it's time
for me to move again this is going to be
like the longest time I've ever stayed
in one place but I've always enjoyed
traveling because you you get to to to
to learn new things come up with new
ideas meet new people and so I've never
passed up the opportunity to do so and
even though I'd only been here I think
about a year ago when I got the
invitation to come here was both
flattered by such a prestigious
invitation but also excited to come back
again to CEO and when I was here last
time a projector look very much like
that one blue and in the middle of my
talk I think so I thought that's great
i'll come and i'll just finish the talk
that i started back back then and so
it's really a pleasure to be here and i
look forward to talking more with more
of you after the after the presentation
and i did choose a fairly broad title
but i think in fact i'll try to convince
you that it sounds broad but in fact
sustainable development extinction in
climate change are really just various
forms of one particular kind of a goal
that we have as a modern society and and
have to deal with in terms of shaping
our environment before i start anything
i always want to acknowledge my lab
before i forget this is these are Maya
my members of my lab because in reality
especially as the years progress what do
I do that screen thanks
now I seen some heads all right we all
have to i'll have to echolocate so I so
I said just all in white rather than
black so so our motto has has always
been ecology with no apology because I
had discovered as I became an ecologist
including my mother you know people i
would meet would feel that somehow this
was a lesser science and i had become
convinced that it was one of the more
powerful sciences that were to our
disposal for trying to solve very very
complex problems and actually moved from
a starting career in cell biology over
to ecology as i became attracted to the
complexity of issues they addressed and
I also find it a great privilege and a
great deal of fun to be the director of
a lab the chair of a department somebody
who actually gets to try to shape
tomorrow's generation and train them and
provide them with tools and work with
them to deal with some of these very
very complex problems so most of what
I'm going to be talking about really
they get the credit for it anything that
actually you find suspicious I'll take
responsibility for that I'd like to
start with this slide which is actually
a slide I ended with with the last time
I was here and I put it together for a
number of reasons but mostly to try to
get us to think about exactly what it is
that sustainable development is doing
for us and the four panels involve
looking at a variety of different sort
of metrics that tell us what the state
of our planet has been for the last 20
or so years you see I'm starting with
1980 the very top one is annual growth
in GDP a sort of measure of economic
growth if you will or economic power the
next panel below that is the share
population on less than a dollar a day
very commonly used metric of poverty I
know it's very controversial one I
myself don't like it but it is in use
I'm going to use that as a measure of
poverty
this next panel contains to what i would
consider our sort of iconic measures of
the change of our planet that are very
worrisome and attract a lot of attention
one is the Living Planet Index which is
one of the most widely used indices for
the state of biodiversity on earth and
the other is the Keeling curve which
shows the increasing amount of carbon
dioxide in our atmosphere which tells us
about global warming but also many other
things about global change and then this
bottom one here is probably not a metric
you've seen before it is the number of
times that you can find the word
sustainable development being used in
the literature if you go to the
LexisNexis index and you will be not too
surprised by the fact that it was almost
not used at all and then there was a big
spike when we had the publication of our
common future or the brundtland report
which was actually a call to the world
to abandon the traditional approaches in
economic development which mostly
involved spending down our natural
capital as they say in order to build up
human and man-made capital and what that
meant was that we tended to improve our
lot in life by spending most of our
natural world in order to achieve that
now if you look at the upper panel and
then the panel's below that but I wanted
to argue is that before and after I
would say that I don't really
particularly see any evidence at all
that sustainable development even though
it's being widely embraced by many many
people at least we those who write about
it or write blogs about actually
LexisNexis is now actually citing uses
of words and blogs and other sort of
internet forums so there's quite a
change that spike beer as you can see
was the 2002 meeting in Johannesburg
where we had sort of Earth Summit too so
I'm not surprising there was a lot of
material that came out shortly before
and after that on sustainable
development but it doesn't really look
like economic growth has changed very
much if you look at the indices of
poverty you can see there's been a rapid
decline in asian levels of poverty and
now sub-saharan Africa is the economic
region which dominates but again there
really doesn't seem to be
any influence of sustainable development
if you look at the biodiversity and the
climate change indices again no evidence
for it and yet i would say that perhaps
short of religion this represents one of
the most rapidly increasing
subscriptions to an idea that one could
probably document in recent history if
you if so many people are really and you
can see it's just skyrocketing still I
shudder to think how many publications
have come out today at this point here
we had 50 publications per day coming
out on the term sustainable development
now Columbia University we have a you
know we're starting a new major in
sustainable development we have the
Earth Institute which is dedicated to
promoting the idea and the concept of
sustainable development and I actually
one of those subscribers as well but
when you see these it does make you ask
yourself is there something different we
can do so that we can actually find
these indices starting to change in
directions we would expect the embracing
of sustainable development to achieve my
model for the way the world works I
think which actually brings a
sustainable development into it is is is
a fairly complicated one but i think if
we were to use this as the way of
understanding how the world works that
there is what we call natural capital
varies our biodiversity there are
ecosystems and they provide us with a
large number of what are called
ecosystem services benefits that we
derive from the natural world and then
we also have managed ecosystems which
provide us with a lot of other benefits
as well that we sitting in the center
here are actually deriving our goods and
services from both of these different
pools of resources and fluxes of energy
now right now we've strapped on a couple
of Tanks one full of fossil fuel and the
other full of fossil water and we're
able to sort of keep things going at
levels that are really not sustainable
without those those two sort of tanks
strapped on to it but the question that
I think we are trying to struggle with
right now is whether or not the
continuous growth of this and the
continuous decline of that is something
that really will
help to change the world in a way that
is going to improve things the argument
about sustainable development is that
rather than using traditional
development which basically starved this
portion of the model for resources and
fed this one we might tweak the valves
differently so that we can actually get
the balance of goods and services that
we think are best for Humanity now let's
go back to what I do as a scientist and
you'll notice the sharp contrast between
this vision of the world and the one I
just showed you which i think is a
little bit more penetrable I have to say
I love this stuff even seeing it now I
get so excited I yearn to go back to be
a graduate student and argue about these
sorts of questions these are ecological
frameworks and I'm actually allowing
ourselves to go all the way back to to
Aristotle which I think he had a
beautiful way of dividing everything up
into the earth and just those four
elements plus the quintessential but as
we move out through time we've had
different ideas about how best to
understand nature when we had the
parasail scenes and began to throw off
the sort of shackles if you will of
Aristotelian thinking we began to see
much more order in the world although
here you can see that humans were
largely seen as sort of slaves to nature
which was that nurturing figure up there
in the center and then nature was a
slave to God you see that her arm is
chained to that angry arm coming out of
the cloud up at the top there but you
can see the the the biosphere the
geosphere the atmosphere elementum
aureus here people begin beginning to
have a grander view of the world what's
happened since then of course is much
more fractionation but it allowed us
with a bit more power here's the idea
from Bob pain about predators be playing
prominent roles in structuring nature
this is from Linda men who argued that
it was the flux of material and energy
that structured nature and I could go on
this one here simply says that mostly
climate and physical factors determine
where you'd find nature evolution
structures nature food web structures
nature and all of these things are
incredible fun and I think actually the
right way to go about doing science but
sometimes hard to
how to translate this kind of research
that we do in our laboratories to the
kind of figure I'd shown you before so
what I'm going to try to do today is
present to you some material from this
volume which just came out this summer
in which after five years a lot of us
who are sort of your card carrying
ecological scientists were involved
mostly in academic settings try to
struggle with the question about how can
we take the science that's associated
with the study of biodiversity in the
study of ecosystems and apply it to real
world problems you see the cover here
shows the transition of a bornean forest
here up in the front they were down on
the bottom to one up at the top which is
an oil palm plantation which is what a
lot of Borneo is becoming and the
tremendous diversity in here we feel is
something that provides a lot of value
and a lot of services for people but the
oil palm plantation provides a lot of
services as well so I'm just giving you
a list of some of the topics that are in
here what I'm going to show you is the
kind of science that I've been involved
with that was the foundation for this
edited volume to be produced and then
show you a chapter in it which I found
actually fairly disturbing about what it
is we do as scientists and then perhaps
share with you some ideas about how we
might reconsider the way we do our
science so this is actually the model
that the group of people involved in
trying to consider how biological
diversity and the function of the
ecosystems actually relate to our
well-being not too different from the
diagram I started with a little bit
earlier but you can see we are now
recognizing that people in that box up
at the top are deriving what they need
from a living planet and that living
planet is actually very complex in its
structure and as a colleges we found a
home for the study of food webs the
study of evolution the study of
functional ecology the study of
biogeography but we also recognize that
all of that structure influenced the way
inorganic nutrients moved into and out
of the pools things like
nitrogen and carbon and other sorts of
elements as well as water and that what
we wanted to understand was if you were
to change anything inside this box here
if you were to change the food web
relations change the biogeography change
the functional ecology of the species
how is it that people would be affected
would it be good would it be bad and the
the diagram we had to show the richness
of scientific ideas i think is a
wonderful graph because it shows two
things one is that we all agreed that if
there was no biodiversity there would be
no ecosystem functioning now that might
seem strange to a lot of people but in
actuality if you get rid of all of the
plants animals and microorganisms there
is no such thing as an ecosystem so it
is somewhat puzzling that people study
them independently the other thing that
all of us agreed with was that if there
was some biodiversity especially as a
natural level you would get some
ecosystem functioning but if you look
between those two points you can see you
have two ways of describing it either a
tremendous amount of disagreement or as
I said before a richness of ideas for
which we can pursue this and i would say
that even to this date the there is some
debate surrounding what would happen if
we were to take a community and then
watch it lose its species lose elements
of his diversity in and measure in some
way what would happen to the way that
system performed or function are
provided us with the goods and service
we need i asked some students when i was
working in grasslands in the university
of minnesota to try to articulate that
idea students as they always will do
came up with this great system of
building a box that sort of represents
in many ways a diagram that i just
showed in this box they placed on top of
a plot of a grassland and here we have
an infrared gas analyzer that measures
how much carbon dioxide is in the box
and if you move the box from plot to
plot the plot this is what you'll find
out now they only kept the box on the
plots for about 60 seconds because it
gets very hot in Minnesota inside a
plastic box and so you just have to keep
it moving but if you look at the carbon
dioxide in the Box it starts out about
33
Radio 3 40 parts per million which is
fairly standard for the atmosphere
certainly out there in the middle of the
day but immediately immediately the
carbon dioxide starts to be drawn out of
that box pulled into the vegetation
taken out of the atmosphere by all of
the plants that are inside that box and
you can see actually if this was some
measure of the atmosphere of our planet
we would be heading for some terribly
cold glacial period but of course it was
just in a little box and we had a
dramatic reduction in the amount of
carbon dioxide once once we sealed it
off but the interesting thing here is if
you actually look at the number of plant
species that's in that box if you have
one species or two species compared to
12 or 24 you have very different rates
of how much carbon dioxide is being
drawn out of the atmosphere what I like
about this is you can imagine right now
as we sit around talking about how is it
we're going to address this horrible
thing of climate change which is
dramatically altering so many features
of our planet you might think if this is
the only information that you wanted
seems like the answer is obvious
increased plant diversity but it turns
out of course not to be that that simple
but it did draw attention to the idea
that the diversity of life itself is
something that is very important in
understanding how ecosystems function
and so the paper that actually I think
got a lot of us thinking about this was
what I my colleagues did when I was a in
England and what we had done was built
some some artificial ecosystems as you
will as you as you might consider them
inside growth chambers we have lots of
species of plants and decomposers and
insects which fed on them and we had
predatory insects as well and then some
of the chambers had a smaller number of
species still very complex communities
but a lot of biodiversity had been lost
and then we had some chambers which had
very little biodiversity compared to the
others and we measured again carbon
dioxide which I think drew a lot of
attention inside the box and we show
that if you look at the the chambers
which have the highest level of
diversity in them they were the ones
which actually drew down the most carbon
dioxide out of the box if you closed it
for 72 hour care
now this is showing what happened over
about 200 days so in the early stages
when there wasn't much going on in the
Box just small baby planets not much
what's happening but they became very
distinct communities the bio diverse
world the species rich world was the one
that was doing a better job of drawing
carbon dioxide out of the box over a
72-hour period that was a nicer study of
course than what was done by the
students in the in the field because at
nighttime of course we expect carbon
dioxide to be going in the other
direction so it was nice to average it
over three days rather than just 60
seconds so now what I'm going to show
you is a series of scientific
experiments and they'll have little
graphs as decorations for the scientists
in the audience who will not believe
that what I'm saying actually should be
said unless I can back it up by some
sort of rigorous studies but actually
I'm not that intrigued by the grass but
if you want to talk about these I'll be
happy to talk about them later I'm just
going to summarize with many years of
research has shown one of the complaints
and criticisms we had early on with that
experiment in the growth chamber was we
didn't have enough trophic levels with
that men is we didn't have enough things
like predators and prey species and
producer species like plants and so I
decided well you know the easiest way to
do that experiment would be to do with
microbial species and there you have
plants a variety of herbivores and
predators which were protozoa and then
lots of decomposes which were bacteria
and what these graphs are showing is
that if you looked across a variety of
different microcosms or bottles that
have microbial communities that range
from very very low diversity and these
would be the very very low diversity
bottles two bottles which have lots of
species per trophic level lots of
predators lots of prey lots of producers
lots of decomposers that you found that
you would find that the amount of
primary productivity in those bottles
was higher but also that the bottles
produced a certain quantity of biomass
much more predictably than they did in
the absence of lots of diversity the
less diverse the world became the more
unpredictable it became and in fact PETA
morn at Rutgers University have done a
very similar study
he and his lab we didn't know that we
were both doing this and that paper had
come out in the I think in the very next
issue after hours or before hours and
showing pretty much the same thing and I
had said where we had said that the loss
of biodiversity basically made your
world less reliable and Peter Morin and
colleagues said that the loss of
biodiversity major were less predictable
and that I thought should be something
that people should be concerned about
one of my favorite experiments was led
by Peter I she's at the University
maraton Minnesota in this one here where
again manipulating the diversity of
plants each one of those plots plots
contains different numbers of plant
species but we're also manipulating the
amount of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere by controlling how much
carbon dioxide flows into the atmosphere
with a series of pumps in a very very
large tank of carbon dioxide there's
another set of plots which has these
pipes around it but rather than spewing
carbon dioxide over the plots they
simply spew empty air so that's the
control and Peter eyes had decided we
would manipulate plant diversity and
carbon dioxide by those pipes and we'd
also manipulate the amount of nitrogen
fertilizer added to the plots as well so
what we were trying to do is to say I'm
more to find out which matters more okay
if I were to ask you all if I would go
to do Poland's room and I were to ask
you what's the worst thing in the world
it's happening right now is that the
loss of biodiversity is it the doubling
of atmospheric carbon dioxide or is it
the doubling of nitrogen in all of our
ecosystems that comes from the use of
fertile fertilizers and from our
industrial activities some people argue
that this is the worst some people argue
that that's the worst and some people
argue that that's the worst so this
experiment was set up to test all three
of them lots of results have come out of
it i'm just going to show you one of
them because i think it has a very nice
way of showing the difference between a
world which is enriched in carbon
dioxide the world which is enriched with
nitrogen and a world which is enriched
with both and what we're doing is we're
comparing how much plant biomass we got
out of these plots with the controls
which had no added co2 no added nitrogen
and-and-and-and had neither of them at
at the same time those are the the
completely saturated ones in terms of
what was at it and if you look down here
each of these bars represent whether the
plot had one species four species nine
species or 16 species and I think you
can see as you move from the left to the
right but always the biggest change that
occurs was whether you're going from
monocultures to poly cultures not
whether you're going to elevated co2 or
two elevated n or two elevation in both
co2 again but the biggest change will
happen when you look at how the change
in biodiversity and we had argued not
that biodiversity was more important
than the other two but that so many
people were focused on nitrogen
pollution and so many people were
focused on carbon dioxide that it was
time to start including biodiversity as
well and this was the another study that
Ted Kennedy my student who is not a
senator who took taking the lead on this
project we had in the same large
experiments a Dave Thoman and set up at
Cedar Creek got students to watch how
invasive species were colonizing the
plot again lots of tiny graphs to just
to convince you that it was a rigorous
study but the take home message from
this as you heard in some of the titles
Jeffrey had extracted from my CV was
that if you look in plots which have
lots of species in them like here we
have the number of species out of there
were 24 species you would find that the
size of the plants that were exotics or
invasives the number of exotics are
invasives and also how crowded the
exotics the natives of the exotic
species were by the native plants was
always something that was associated
with the increase in biological
diversity it was really hard for an
invasive species to get into a plot
which was highly diverse because it was
very crowded and very hard to make a
living it sort of makes sense you might
imagine that if you arrived in New York
right now with a particular skill
candlestick maker a butcher a baker it
is funny because you don't see too many
of those people anymore but you would
find to be very hard to set up shop in
New York because there are so many
candlestick makers butchers and bakers
but if you went to a community we
didn't have those setting up shop would
be a lot easier to do and that's what
this study suggested biodiversity was
also valuable for trying to control the
the terrible scourge of invasive species
that better that are occurring
everywhere um then another study we did
which has even tinier graphs this was
done by Dan bunker when we were at
Columbia and a bunch of colleagues we
actually asked how much carbon is stored
in a in a 50 hectare plot panamanian
rainforest the famous follow barro
Colorado rainforest in lots of graphs
but again what our message was was that
the more by diverse plots were the ones
which contain the most carbon and as you
lost by diversity the ones which were
more predictable in terms of how much
carbon they were storing were the ones
which were the most diverse so if you
are paying somebody to store your carbon
rather than paying them to store your
money if they were going to be your bank
for carbon you would really want to find
a banker whose whose bank in this case a
forest is made up of lots of species
because not only they can be able to
store money for you they're going to
store it more reliably for you to then
somebody who has a low diversity for us
I can't help is it Tom Lovejoy sitting
up here in the front I can't help
remember when he said that valuing
rainforest for their carbon storage was
like valuing your computer for the
silicon that it contains and I always
thought that some was a little bit of
trepidation I put this up in front of
him because he's probably saying how can
you reduce that wonderful rainforest to
how much carbon is stored but my answer
is is what people do and we were just
trying to get them to stop looking at
green pixels and satellite images and
say how much carbon is there but look at
that pixel and say how many species are
inside that pixel and give those people
more carbon credits if that's what
you're going to do I'm doing a lot more
research now with colleagues at the
Institute of botany the Chinese national
academy of sciences and we are looking
at the certification in the inner
mongolian grassland our contribution is
to try to find out the role of
biological diversity and trying to stay
deserted vacation that's occurring as
people are increasing their herds I do
think that the science can actually be
brought directly to questions of applied
issues I wasn't so happy working here
because in fact most of the native
mammals are gone
Inner Mongolia I actually tried to
convince them maybe we should go to
Mongolia and bring some of them back for
the experiment but they thought it was
an interesting idea then they gave up so
we're mostly working with sheep cattle
and goats which I suppose are cute in
their own way but just not part of the
system I was looking for okay so I felt
as a scientist I wanted to show you or
share with you what it is we do a
scientist because you might wonder how
do you come you know come come about to
make those bold statements in our
scientific papers titles at saying that
biodiversity makes an ecosystem more
reliable or saying that biodiversity can
lead to the exclusion of invasive
species that's how we do it but you
might still quibble with each one of
those speech one of those studies by
saying well that's just in Minnesota or
that's just with plants well what can
you really learn from microbes in a
bottle I mean why don't you go out there
and study a system with tigers and
elephants and and people in it well
what's happened over the span of some 15
years is there have been about 900
studies on this topic and for me as a
scientist I can't think of another area
in science that has had so many
different kinds of studies that have
devoted themselves to this question what
is the role of biodiversity in the way
our ecosystem serve us or the way
because this was function I won't go
into the meta analysis as it's called
because now there's so many studies
people can actually conduct studies that
study other studies but i'll give you
the take-home line that they provided
Brad cardinale at all had concluded from
their analysis of mostly terrestrial and
freshwater studies that their findings
that they're finding was that the key
aspects of ecosystem functioning
declined consistently with the average
species loss suggest that a
precautionary approach to preserving as
much biodiversity as possible is
warranted and I thought yes that's a
great message to you have come out of 15
years and 900 studies and in the very
same year Boris worm and a bunch of
colleagues published this very extensive
review of the marine literature coming
to pretty much the same conclusion as we
see in land and freshwater again I'll
read from them rather than paraphrasing
it worm it all says in their paper
positive relationships between births
diversity an ecosystem funk
and services were found using
experimental and correlative approaches
along trajectories of diversity loss and
recovery our data highlight the societal
consequences of an ongoing erosion of
diversity that appears appears to be
accelerating on a global scale right now
in a way you might say well we sort of
knew that biodiversity was declining at
a global scale and happening fairly
quickly for drawing attention to it in
marine systems was very important
because there is a lot of attention
that's given to rest real systems
because we don't see what's going on
under the water as well it says also
here I thought this is another important
conclusion this trend is of serious
concern and if you can get the word
serious concern into an article like
that in science that means that the the
people who reviewed it were convinced
that it was indeed series we tend to be
so conservative in our language because
it projects the global collapse of all
taxa currently fished by the mid 21st
century can you imagine that every
single taxa that has represents a major
fishery in the ocean will collapse by
the middle of the 21st century or in
just a few in just a few decades so in
thinking about this a little bit further
I decided well how about in and this is
I'm going to show you the last study
which i think is great fun because it
does something but I think scientists
need to do and that is that if we were
to look at what some of the major
reasons for the loss of biodiversity is
there's no question that converting
natural ecosystems to manage ecosystems
like farms or croplands and pastures is
the major cause for biodiversity loss
and while some people might say well
there's still a lot of diversity in
those farmlands and pasture lands if you
actually look at the diversity that's
there you'll find that it's not it's
nothing compared to you to you what used
to be there prior to the to the
intervention and here you know if you
look at even the way those systems are
managed here's a forest which is hardly
managed at all the grassland which has
very little management here's a complex
agricultural system maybe perhaps with
many crops and with them other sorts of
things that will make it less intensity
manav modified like a monoculture of
corn in the Midwest
you can see that if you look at the
effect size on the loss of biodiversity
and the changes in the way these
ecosystems are functioning it gets much
worse as you increase the amount of
intensity that we apply to managing our
ecosystems so we decided to take a look
at the Great Plains because there's a
lot of data for the Great Plains and our
government has provided us in one of the
rare instances where they show some
appreciation for biodiversity here is a
set of postage stamps which says what
the prairie might have looked like of
course with a lot of biodiversity sort
of condensed in there and this is what
it looks like today there's the Great
Plains being show to you in a map this
is a picture what it might have looked
like you know looking at a Preserve
where there's some bison today and
taking a photograph of that and then now
we still have a grassland it's fairly
simple in terms of Biological Diversity
I imagine that except for the little
gullies where there might be some other
species this is mostly one species there
will be still brazzers out there but
just probably one species the cattle
maybe some sheep and then we'll also
have some some forbes as well like corn
or legumes so it's not it's not
incredibly devoid of diversity you can
have wheat and rye and corn and so forth
but nothing like here where you might
have up to 200 species of grasses and
forbs in a variety of different species
of mammals and so our question was well
maybe still people feel like this this
is you know I think this is the kind of
thing that we wave the flag when we see
it gives us a sense of pride that we
have been able to manage our ecosystem
to provide us at least with one
ecosystem service food very very well
the question is how have we change this
some people might feel this is still a
grassland it has grazers it has grasses
just like that from there and what we
decided to do is to use what I think is
the most modern approach to studying
this problem is to look at what we call
the traits of the species there and how
they have changed over time you see we
can't go back to the Prairie the
prairies gone is about 1% of the Prairie
your left in some states about 0.1% of
the Prairie there are prairie reserves
but they're often strange little
anomalous things that are hard to study
but we can use what we know about the
prairie plants and try to construct what
the prayer
would be like and compare it to what it
is today and we had four different ideas
about what the modern world is like
compared to the old world the old world
is shown is that green cube there and
then the blue world is going to be shown
as the as the as the modern agricultural
world we're calling these hulls because
that's geometric name for these
particular shapes and for convenience
we're showing it as a rectangular solid
it can be any shape you might imagine
but where we're looking at four
different arguments one is that the
modern world the agricultural world is
simply not as diverse in its capacity to
deal with environmental challenges like
drought or like frost or like floods or
fires and so forth and it really has
just become a shrunken vision a shrunken
version of what the old world was like
some people might argue that the modern
world is better than the old world these
plants have been bred and genetically
engineered to do things plants have
never done before this is the modern
world you know get with the program and
and stop wringing your hands about the
loss of the Prairie here's another
argument is that they're just different
systems right the shifting centroid
they're somewhat related but they're
different worlds now and they have to
you know require different ideas about
how to manage them and how to treat them
and what to expect for them the other
possibility is that they're entirely
different they're not relate at all to
say that a farmland in the Midwest is a
grassland is a mistake it's something
that just never has been on this planet
before and so this is the thing I think
every scientist has to do in the modern
age is to throw up a rotating
three-dimensional diagram which is
absolutely inscrutable because can he
really feel like we are doing science
and it's in it's a hardest core sense of
the word but what this actually does I
think actually graphically aside from
its aesthetic appeal is shows very
nicely the end of the result of that
analysis which was done by Brenda Lin
who is now on Triple A s fellowship in
Washington DC but she was in our lab for
a for a couple of years and she led this
this study this blue shape here is what
the modern world looks like that green
shape is what the Prairie looked like
and what that says if you think of that
as sort of the capacity for an
system to provide us with services and
to respond to environmental challenges
there's enormous capacity in the Prairie
and if you look at the modern world as
Brenda lynnwood disco describe it it's a
cheaply built fast run world that
actually has no capacity to deal with
with environmental change you might ask
yourself well how is it this thing
exists at all and the answer is this
because we fertilize it we irrigate it
when it gets eaten we used biocides we
manage it we take care of it and once
upon a time the Prairie didn't really
need all of that tending on the other
hand and this is a fair statement that
is inedible largely and this is very
very edible they can eat most of the
biomass that's produced there and if you
can't eat it you can feed it to the cows
and then you can eat that so we do have
to consider what it is that people are
asking to get out of the ecosystem
services so remember in the beginning i
said i was going to share with you
however this you know the very
disturbing study that my colleague did
martin solon didn't it was a chapter he
submitted for our book and this is the
very disturbing study it's probably
disturbing because you think that guy's
crazy to put such a slide up but you
know that's partly to show you how
complex the thinking was behind Martin
sullen and alls analysis and what they
did is they actually asked what is the
impact of scientific research in the
real world have managers has legislation
has anybody been influenced by the nine
hundred different studies at which I've
shown you a large number of samples been
published over the last 15 years and
they had to come up for a model of how
to answer that question and for our
research biodiversity and its impact on
ecosystem functioning they argue that it
starts out with hypothesis generation it
has to go through a period of laboratory
experiments and field experiments and
when they're iterations back and forth
among two scientists how to do better
research that expands it goes through a
reality filter where we start to de mis
dismiss theories that don't seem to make
sense and dismiss laboratory and simple
studies that don't make sense and start
to do more larger complex studies for
many years and then eventually we start
to use that data in our models to make
prediction about the what the world will
be like in the future and I think I
showed you just for the research we're
doing exactly this sort of trend the
last study I showed you was trying to
make a statement about what the world
was like in the past and what it is now
based entirely on models not actually
trying to go out and do field
experiments or laboratory experiments
but in the end in the end if your
science is worth anything it has to get
down here to the application in the real
world now I have to say that I don't
agree exactly with that but many people
will say that if it doesn't get down to
this lower level here where it can be
extended to landscape levels where we
can understand the implications of our
research beyond the growth chamber in
the small plot where we can connect it
to ecosystem services beyond just food
but things like oxygen production in the
pin the purification of water when we
can translate it to policy when we can
actually aid management and conservation
when we can provide expert advice then
the science has truly managed to
penetrate where we would hope that it
could go ultimately and this was the
disturbing study it's again another
small diagram but what they did was they
took the sixth most widely studied a
cited papers in that field so there's
six of them up here and they followed it
through the literature and I think what
you can see even though it's hard to see
all the detail is that it gets cited a
lot they influenced other studies cited
a lot the influence of other studies
cited a lot of influence other study but
it Peters out okay and it never made it
except for a couple of instances to the
applied world it hardly showed up in
legislation that hardly showed up in
management plans it hardly showed up in
journals that deal with applied issues
like journals of rangeland management
and so forth and here we were having all
this fun doing the science believing
that the science would change the world
and coming and some of you might say
well you should have known that to the
realization realization that we have to
take a different approach if we're going
to get through that final hurdle and get
it into the applied world because this
this is where I work now Molly Inner
Mongolia and Kenya and you can see that
our world is becoming fairly homogeneous
populated by domestic species and
largely something
that does not have the kind of
biodiversity that provided us with so
many of the services that made us the
successful species we are in the first
place and it's true in the climate
models and this is how I get the climate
change in what I was going to talk about
today I was very excited as many people
were to see the latest IPCC report but
disappointed again that one more
iteration of it still wound up having a
very simplistic idea about the world was
I mean the world does the climate models
now have vegetation in them and they're
much more complex and they ever have
been before and they're much high
resolution certainly it is an
improvement over the idea that we could
just treat the world is sort of a swamp
and then eventually get to one where we
have a lot more topography and a lot
more variability in the vegetation and
that the vegetation would interact with
the climate system but to me as someone
who studies biodiversity until climate
models start to have that kind of
perspective i really wonder if they can
give us the kind of precision about
ecosystem services that we're hoping for
that would go beyond simply telling us
the major sorts of ways climate will
change which is important but i don't
think sufficient i believe we have the
technology and the know-how to do so if
those working on biodiversity can stop
now working more closely with the
geochemists who do the climate modeling
so here's the last paper I want to share
with you which just came out I think
this week or last week and you can see
this is the Arctic ecosystem and if you
look at the amount of snow and you look
at the mouth of ice you can see that the
cover has been declining dramatically
over the last few years it's funny
however in the 1980s as graduate
students we were pretty convinced that
climate change was about as solidly
demonstrated as possible one could
possibly do it seems like only now it
has the kind of traction it should have
had a long time ago but it's great that
everybody's getting on the climate
change bandwagon studies like this
especially up in the north which give us
an example of what's going to happen
further south where when you're looking
at the timing of flowerings of plants
and seeing that they're all shifting to
earlier in the season when you're seeing
that Fox's like the red fox are
migrating north and displacing the
arctic fox shown there and it's white
coat when you see that insect herbivores
are now having outbreak
like they've never had before and the
vegetation of the northern climes and if
you look at things like them the fact
that the the reindeer populations are
growing because the there's less
mortality due to the cold and there's
more exposed vegetation and even more
sort of strange things like the lemming
cycles that we were all so familiar with
the idea that all these lemmings sort of
threw themselves off the cliff
periodically when in fact they were just
crowded and falling off the cliff but
you can see that those very regular
cycles which I remember being tested on
my orals exam as to what the leading
hypotheses were at the time for the
lemming cycles well it doesn't seem like
it's worth asking that question anymore
because the lease of recent history
they're not cycling the way they used to
do before and there are other changes
that are occurring so I actually went to
the Arctic this summer for the first
time all my friends work in the south so
I just had to go on my own and I have to
say that as an ecologist going up here
and being exposed to this kind of system
it's incredible starkness with
challenges I cannot imagine any animal
could survive and then seeing a richness
of diversity that is unbelievable you
really have to go and walk around and
spend a few days there to see what an
amazing place it is for such a stark
landscape that this is really the kind
of thing that we learned about
biodiversity its richness and taxonomy
behavior morphology all those things
that means so much to us culturally
culturally but in addition to all of
that diversity what's happening is that
those species played a role in the
ecosystem that they were found in we
look at these deer some bear some of you
might see them as cute some of them
might see them as sort of icons for
climate change or reasons for us to
think more about the Endangered Species
Act and what it means and so forth but
when I see the bear and I think when
many researchers see the bear now we
recognize that they are important
components to a functioning system
regulating the species which feed on
fish which feed on feed on plankton
which affect the microbial community and
ultimately govern things like the amount
of oxygen is being produced we met via
the color of the water the release of
compounds from the from the
many many other things that affect
climate so this is my last slide I was
really pleased when working in China to
come across this sign it was actually a
sort of sign that sort of says keep off
the grass but but I like the idea as to
why you should think first before you
step on the grass is that civilization
is from every tiny thing and I think
what I've learned and what all of us
have learned from doing so much science
about biodiversity and understanding is
utilitarian value is that it is not an
easy concept to convey to the world but
the burden is on us to try to get it
across I'm really grateful to have the
opportunity to try to spend some time
with you today to share that message
those thanks very much all right how did
you end time yes
sure wow that's a challenging quest the
top three things i would do to to reach
Ainge i guess i'm getting a chance to do
a little bit of that as chair of a
department but i would say that one of
the first things and maybe this comes
from being a chair is to change the way
we train the generation of people who
are going to wind up being involved in
science we have arguments all the time
about how best to do that in our own
department we have argued even at the
last faculty meeting to what extent
should we require our students to learn
about environmental economics
environmental policy or even to learn
other social sciences like psychology
anthropology but I do feel that one of
the reasons that our literature failed
to connect was because we did not have a
broad enough training for our students I
think we're trying to do that
differently at Columbia I know you're
trying to do that differently here at
Yale I guess the second thing is I would
change the funding strategy of course i
would say that we should probably
increase the amount of funding to us
Tanner or ten or a hundred times and
even that probably you know I think it's
very interesting we're spending I love
cosmology I read I think I probably read
the articles about the cosmos before I
get to the articles in ecology maybe
because one is less less depressing than
the other but you know we aren't we
spent something like what is it 60
million dollars on the Kepler satellite
to go and look for other planets and
we're about to spend another 900 million
on planets to go and look for more
satellites a series of three other
satellites that are going to be go
looking for exoplanets I love exoplanets
I think they're really cool of course
they're 350 of them and not one of them
are habitable in any way shape or form
and I think they're about three hundred
light-years away but I think that in
addition to the nine hundred million
dollars we're spending looking for the
exoplanets I think maybe we could spend
nine hundred million dollars looking at
our planet so that's number to change
our funding priorities and I guess the
third thing that i would do is try to
stop the division in the biological
sciences between those who study
biogeochemistry and those who study
biodiversity this group tends to focus
the biodiversity group tends to focus on
behavior and taxonomy and conservation
from the standpoint of demography the
bio geographers 10
look at sort of fluxes of energy and
nutrients and yet these two things are
just inseparable and I find that we
could make tremendous progress by
furthering a few years ago linked to the
scale so how should we take this and you
were lamenting at the end okay this
hasn't made it into papers etc so I
think this is a so the question is how
do you scale up from scientific research
which tends to be very often very small
in scale both in time and in space and
while other sciences don't seem to have
so much of an issue with that certainly
is a problem in Natural Science there's
a expectation especially if managers and
the public for us to demonstrate our
results at a very large scale now you'll
notice if a climate modeling for example
those are computer models with models
which are not based on planet level
experiments right although you might
argue we have one on replicated
experiment going on right now but
they're based on very small studies done
in greenhouses done in growth chambers
done with little infrared gas analyzers
are clipped onto plants and things like
that I think that we can scale up from
the little plot level experiments we've
done now you just have to apply certain
amounts of uncertainty to it the same
way the IPCC has done now the IPCC has
been very successful but it has taken
them more than 20 years to start to
convince people about what it is they're
doing as scientists and to start using
scenarios so they can get their message
beyond just simply the sort of physics
of climate change to the actual social
implications of and I think we can do
that now lita the shorter answer would
be to say that I think we can't do
larger experiments we can
longer term experiments we don't have
the time or the money to do it we can do
modeling and what's happening right now
at least in the last five years in
ecology is people have sort of
rediscovered what's called functional
ecology it's funny how science sort of
goes in out of fashion and comes back
into fashion and where's in the 1930s we
had ronke are going around saying that
plants have different kinds of
functional aspects to them and that got
sort of left behind now there are
tremendous amounts of activity all over
the world where people are collecting
information about what plants do not
just what their systematics are not just
who they are related to texting out
taxonomically but how big are they what
what are the rates of photosynthesis how
much water do they use how much water do
they evaporate what eats them and as we
get more and more information like that
the kinds of computers we have today I
was joking the other day that I could
probably even get an app on my mom my
iphone which could just tell me what the
biodiversity is in this area is and tell
me what the influence of the loss of
that biodiversity would be by using
modeling but it would probably take a
long time before we get everybody to
agree it just exactly how to do that
that's a i miss Monica that's a great
question your question was why was there
greater efficiency of carbon dioxide
drawdown when there was more
biodiversity that was believe it or not
a raging debate in fact I often wondered
if my career would go on another day
because I was worried I'd come out on
the wrong side of the debate and and and
scientists were actually relatively
uncivil at times about the argument as
to whether or not it was an artifact but
more diversity led to greater carbon
dioxide sequestration or whether was a
true effect and even when it was a true
effect which of the possible
explanations accounted for accurately in
the end after nine hundred studies I
don't think anybody's involved in that
debate anymore what we've learned is
that if you see an effect like that you
have to have an explanation for it so in
a way as a postdoc in England I got away
with murder because it was a new finding
and nobody placed that demand on me if I
were to try to publish that study today
I would have to explain why that I have
to answer the question you just asked
well the answer that we have which still
tends to be the most prominent I'll give
you that one is that if you put lots of
different kinds of plants in a space
some will be tall's and will be small
sum will be deep-rooted some will be
shallow rooted that they tend to make
much more efficient use of the resources
in the same space than any monoculture
would do we call that niche
complementarity but there are other
reasons that it could it could occur
there's something called the sampling
effect there's mutualism there are many
other things that people have argued
about I think that one I just described
the niche complement complementarity is
the most common one but it is a it is a
very important thing to do whenever you
do one of these studies if you find in
effect you don't always find it affect
you need to explain why that effect is
so we can answer that question
that is just that you're sending down
co2 from more areas in space sample of
that it's a ventilation problem yes I
luckily phrase it I mean I remember as a
postdoc when i submitted this paper to
nature i said in the end almost i was
thinking to myself you know what we
showed was that if you take a box and
you pack it more efficiently with plants
it will suck down more carbon dioxide
and that didn't strike me as he's like
the most incredible discovery and i was
stunned that within five years so you
know i'm a postdoc i'm a bit uncertain
whether an academic careers the right
career you should make anyways you know
and the paper became the fifth most
cited paper and global change research
really quickly and then somebody said
somebody said i was excited by that as a
postdoc and somebody said noble you
should go and see who's citing you boy
was that a mistake i have to say about
half the study said you know half the
citations was were something like four
people are so misled by their desire to
save biodiversity they're willing to
publish utter rubbish consider nyeem
1994 you know for someone who hadn't
started a change of track position yet
and being exposed to the the willingness
for us to debate endlessly about
anything as scientists which is also
what makes it fun when there's no career
implications that it was quite quite
starting because you're absolutely right
i kept thinking wow the conclusion was
pretty straightforward right pack a box
with more plants more photosynthesis it
seems that simple and yet it was that
was the focus of a debate for almost a
decade
absolutely so the question was whether
or not we could have an agricultural
system that's diverse inedible and in
fact those systems i'm working on are
all managed systems i'm working with the
earth institute in the millennium
villages with very very poor people very
small holdings of land trying to find
ways for them to improve their their
lives and i think actually that
biodiversity conservation probably means
more to the poor farmer than it does say
to the people in nebraska and you'll be
surprised in tropical countries how
diverse their forests I mean how diverse
their plots & land holdings can be
especially as you go in a landscape
level and the my concern is that it's
not only is it more edible it is vastly
more interesting and then the American
diet which is made up of variations on
the theme of corn as you know and it's
it's interesting to me but what would
you see and this is my concern and I'm
not a developmental economists you know
I don't have to defer to the economist
but my impression right now is that most
of traditional aid and traditional
development practices are to take people
out of those highly diverse situations
now admittedly their populations got
very high and then there was a roach in
erosion and there was you know bad
management and so they're in a trap and
they have two different directions they
can go one is to go the direction that
we keep telling them which tends to be
what a lot of development does get the
genetically engineered crops down there
get the fertilizer in a population that
mostly ate many out there now eating
corn right or we can say let's go back
and take the slower but I think more
sustainable route which is to allow
people to restore what they had before
which is an incredible amount of
diversity before things started to
change now you know this is another one
of those things that people debate quite
a bit because when you get to a place
like this where people are incredibly
poor the first thing you want to do is
help them get a clinic help them get a
food a school and so forth but I feel
that after you've done that you then
need to make it more abide ever stop
with keep trying to get them to be
us now if you saw the the most you know
poverty-stricken regions of the world
are sub-saharan Africa also one of the
most species species rich areas in the
world too and it is a place I think
we're if you can you know if you have
the courage to sort of get out of the
academic IV tower and do some applied
work for which your colleagues will
ridicule you and if you are willing to
work in very poverty-stricken sometimes
politically unstable reasons you'll find
that if you get past all of that you'll
find wonderful people sitting amidst
incredible diversity who are open to
ideas but they do have serious problems
that need to be solved and I sometimes
say you know III b is a new III b is the
department of ecology evolution in
environmental biology i did not name it
that i don't know why they named it so
long that you can type it out on an
envelope but that's the name of our
department I often introduce ourselves
as I think you probably would here in
this room you know i would say that we
are the voice of 30 million species and
a thousand billion tons of biomass that
makes this planet habitable and we
should get the aid agencies and the
funding agencies to realize that what
we're working with is truly the route to
sustainable development then the people
are working on a handful of domestic
species that require an awful lot of
energy and chemical inputs but that's
just my uninformed opinion about it
so so so your question is is really you
know how do we get our science to move
out of the limitations which many people
perceive of the smallness and scale the
technical different difficulties of
interpreting precisely what the results
mean into the applied world and that we
sometimes invoke the precautionary
principle when we see no way out of that
fat dilemma yeah well I have a couple
couple of responses once when I started
to see who was citing my paper when I
was a postdoc and was surprised how many
people were citing it because I thought
it was rubbish I began to worry that
maybe they were right I had done with
something wrong and I thought you know
what if for a few years I had made a
mistake and I'll this has to do with
exoplanets too and I had actually
championed the cause of conserving
Biological Diversity and it turns out it
didn't actually improve production you
know that wouldn't have been as bad a
mistake as saying we don't need it for
primary production right now that's not
the way you should do your science and
that's not the way I do my science but
it is a thought that occurred to me and
i think that the precautionary principle
does come sort of a spin off on that the
reason i brought up i mentioned the
exoplanets is it the very first
exoplanet was actually found by an
astronomer and then he had problems with
his equipment and realized that the
exoplanet he found was actually an
artifact and he retracted his paper but
his method was sound and in the meantime
everybody had embraced his methods and
had found up to 315 planets now they've
even photographed one recently they've
even found a rocky one recently too so
that the field is growing fast there was
a there was a symposium a few years ago
in his honor and he got a standing
ovation for sort of sticking with it so
so it's okay to be wrong as long as you
you know you you're honest about what it
is you're doing what the limitations are
but I think the precautionary principle
applies to almost everything in the
environmental science is it applies in
the Health Sciences as well somehow it's
a tricky thing we have to deal with I
would say when you're dealing with
ecosystem services like the production
of oxygen this is a good time to bring
up the precautionary principle as much
as I love you know agric
systems I think there's something that
represents incredible you know power of
humanity to understand and manipulate
ecosystems when they want to do
something I mean if we told them that
we're going to pay them for oxygen boy
would they retool I was that I was at a
conference on endangered species and I I
said you know look if you were to pay
ranchers X number of dollars per head a
prairie dog they'd be out there on their
horses with big herds of prairie dogs
you know it's a matter of asking what it
is you want the managers to do with the
ecosystem services and incentivizing
that process the thing is that farms are
not managed for oxygen production and
yet that's where forty percent of our
terrestrial photosynthetic surface is
right now it's in farms and it's being
managed for food I don't see why we
can't also management for manage it for
oxygen or carbon and many other things I
bet if you start to do that though
you'll find you'll need a lot more
species than just corn or wheat and not
the best answer for that question
well I think genetically engineered
plants and genetically engineered
materials show tremendous promise for
solving some problems where you know the
problem is intractable while you're
trying to grow a plant in a soil that's
become solidified and there simply are
no edible plants that can grow in that
level of salinity but you can
genetically engineer one that can grow
there that represents some promise right
my concern but you know the flip side of
that is that it tends to encourage this
continuing you know focusing down on
diversity so that if we have a problem
rather than the old day we would go look
for another plant that we could eat
right or perhaps breed a plant that
could survive that we will take an
existing plant like corn or tomato or
something we can genetically engineer
and try to engineer that and so in fact
at one of these earth summit there was a
person who gave a talk about his fantasy
rice but he showed a slide of a rice
plant that would be incredibly efficient
photosynthetic could resist any
herbivore there was out there could
resist any fungal pathogen that was out
there could grow in salt water and you
know I think he would wanted it to grow
in the dark but what I saw was a rice
plant that would be like the weed from
hell because it would you could make
such a plan which obviously you can't
because they're trade-offs more than
likely if you make something that's
tolerant to salt it's going to be less
effective at dealing with other
challenges but that aside I just didn't
see the need I thought why not grow
something other than rice and eat that
now you know not everybody is as
Catholic for hapten their diet as I am
but I love finding out what other people
eat and learning all those different
things and I think it's sad but we're
down to about 40 species or so of plants
and domesticated animals and genetic
engineer just keeps pushing that idea of
going with a small number of species
rather than the genetic pool that's out
there that's enormous what that diagram
showed where i showed the prairie being
this vast green volume that is
reflective of the genetic potential of
the prairie that little tiny blue space
is reflecting the Djinn
matic potential of the Agora ecosystem
the idea is that somehow we can expand
that by genetic engineering to catch up
with the Prairie maybe we could do that
I love technology I have a great deal of
faith in it but I think why not just
compactor the Prairie and start getting
bison and other plants in areas and
figuring how to do all these things at
one time